PROFESSOR: So if you want to
hand in your problem sets, we
have three handouts.
The old problem set solutions,
the new problem set, and we're
also handing out chapter
eight today.
Of course, these are
all on the web.
Reminders of previously
announced events.
Next week I'm going
to be away.
Ralf Koetter will be a
much-improved substitute.
He'll be talking about
Reed-Solomon codes and
Reed-Solomon decoding.
He's one of the world experts
on these things.
He's a great lecturer.
So you're really lucky,
I believe.
I will, of course, look at the
video afterwards and see how
he did, but I'm sure he'll
do it better than I
would have done it.
And midterm is in two weeks.
That's just a reminder.
When I come back, we'll have
a Monday class to go over
anything that Ralf may have
missed, or really anything in
the whole course up through
chapter eight.
You can bring questions
in to that.
I don't know how much I feel
I'll need to embellish and
cover, so I don't know
how much time
there will be for questions.
But that can be a fairly
free form lecture.
And then Ashish is going to run
a review session on the
Tuesday with exactly
the same purpose.
So hopefully that'll put you in
good shape for the midterm.
We have to make up
the midterm.
No idea what's going to
be on the midterm yet.
OK.
Any questions about
these things?
Homework processes going OK?
Office hours?
Solutions?
Everything seems to be
all right so far?
Good.
We're in chapter seven.
I certainly plan to
complete it today.
I'm not going to cover all of
chapter seven, but the key
elements that I want
you to know.
You're responsible only
for what's covered in
class, by the way.
We've talked about a lot
of algebraic objects.
Our main emphasis has been to
get the finite field, and at
this point, we have
prime fields.
Fields with a prime number
p of elements.
And we find that we can
construct such a field by
taking the integers mod p.
You can write that
as z mod p z.
You can equally well consider
this as the equivalence
classes of integers of the
cosets of pz nz which are each
identified by a remainder
or residue r between
0 and p minus 1.
OK.
So basically, the elements of
the field are these remainders
or these cosets.
There are p of them.
We do arithmetic by simply
doing mod p addition and
multiplication.
So if you understand arithmetic
mod p, you
understand this field.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is Fp and
Zp isomorphic?
PROFESSOR: As an additive group,
it's isomorphic to Zp.
Zp we use that notation
for the group.
We use this notation
for the field.
And I write Zp is isomorphic
to Z mod pZ
as a quotient group.
Here I've added in the
multiplication operation mod p
to make this a field.
So this is somewhat more than
just a quotient group.
Sorry.
The notation is supposed to be
more suggestive than precise.
This is not a math class.
I hope it's helpful rather
than otherwise.
OK.
So today, we're going to
construct all the rest of the
finite fields.
By the way, we showed that these
are the only fields with
a prime number of elements.
Today we're going to construct
fields with a prime power
number of elements in a very
analogous way, and it will
turn out -- although I'm not
going to prove this -- that
these are the only
finite fields.
Well, these are generalization
of this, so all finite fields
have a prime power number of
elements and are basically
isomorphic to one
of these fields.
How do we construct
this field?
To give you a preview, very
analogously to the way we
constructed this field.
You'll see that the character
of the arguments is
very much the same.
And that's because there is a
great algebraic similarity
between the integers and the
polynomials over a field.
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
Basically, they're both
countably infinite rings, or
infinite rings.
Countably infinite if it's
over a finite field.
And they both have analogous
factorization properties.
They're both unique
factorization domains, would
be one characterization,
algebraically.
All right.
How do we construct
this field?
We're basically going to
construct it by taking the set
of all polynomials over Fp which
is denoted by Fp square
brackets x.
And we're going to take that mod
the set of all polynomials
that are divisible by G of x, or
G of x times the set of all
polynomials.
The set of all multiples
of G of x.
Or more simply, just
mod G of x.
Where we're going to take G of
x to be a prime polynomial.
And I guess I have to add that
the degree of G of x is going
to be equal to m.
So we basically need to find a
prime polynomial degree m.
Then we take the set of all
polynomials modulo this prime
polynomial.
They're going to be exactly p
to the m residue classes, or
equivalence classes, or
remainders modulo g of x.
And we'll use the arithmetic
operations from mod G of x
arithmetic, addition mod G of x,
multiplication mod G of x,
and we'll find that the
resulting object has satisfied
the axioms of the field.
OK?
So that's where we're going.
You with me?
OK.
So let's talk about
factorization.
And I think it makes it easy to
understand polynomials if
we understand the analogies
to the integers.
In particular where I'm headed
is unique factorization.
Both the integers and the
polynomials have unique
factorizations.
The integers into product of
integers, and any polynomial
is uniquely factorizable into
a product of polynomials.
Now I wasn't quite precise
when I said that.
We have to be a little bit
more precise when we talk
about factorization.
In particular, we have a
certain kind of trivial
factorization that
involves units.
Units, if you remember, are
the invertible elements.
We're in a ring, so not every
element has an inverse, but
some of them do.
And in the integers, what were
the invertible integers under
multiplication?
Everything here is about
multiplication, you know?
A ring is something that
satisfies all of the
properties of the field,
except that some of the
elements don't have inverses,
so that division is not
necessarily well-defined, even
for non-zero elements.
OK?
Sorry.
I think I said that before.
But we're not emphasizing
that these are rings,
although they are.
That's an informal definition.
So in the integers, of course
12 doesn't have a
multiplicative inverse,
but it's an integer.
But which integers do have
multiplicative inverses?
Plus or minus 1.
So if an integer is divisible
by n, it's also
divisible by minus n.
All right?
Trivially.
These are the only ones
in the integers.
And last time we actually
talked, if I remember
correctly, about the units
and the polynomials.
Which polynomials
have inverses?
Excuse me.
The degree 0.
Thank you.
The degree 0 polynomials have
inverses because they are
basically the non-zero elements
of the field.
OK?
It's slight abuse of notation.
We identify the field elements
with the degree zero
polynomials.
These are polynomials just of
the form F of x equals F_0 a
constant, where the constant
is non-zero.
OK.
So similarly, we will have to
have representatives of
equivalence classes with
respect to the units.
So if both plus or minus n
divide something, what we take
as the representative is we take
the positive integers.
When we talk about divisibility,
we talk only
about divisibility by positive
integers or factorization by
positive integers.
It's trivial that if something
is divisible by n, it's also
divisible by minus n.
Similarly for polynomials, the
representatives are taken as
mnemonic polynomials.
And this means that the highest
order term, Fm is
equal to 1.
So we can take any polynomial,
and by multiplying it by one
of these invertible elements,
basically by a non-zero
constant in the ground field, we
can make the highest order
term equal to 1.
Right?
So if a polynomial is divisible
by F of x, it's also
divisible by alpha F of x, where
alpha is any non-zero
field element, right?
And so we may as well fix the
highest order coefficient
equal to 1.
Actually, for some purposes in
the literature, like you've
probably seen this in filter
design, or we always make the
lowest order coefficient
equal to one.
F0 equal to 1.
You could also adopt that
convention, and say that
that's going to be a mnemonic
polynomial.
Here we'll focus on the high
order coefficient, but you
could do it either way.
And these both have the nice
property that the product of
positive integers is
a positive integer.
The product of monic polynomials
is a monic
polynomial, right?
The highest order term of the
product is going to have a
highest order term equal to 1.
Or if you chose the
lowest order one,
that would work, too.
The lowest order term of the
product would be equal to 1.
All right.
So having recognized this,
when we talk about unique
factorization, just as with the
integers, what we really
mean is factorization of a
positive integer into a
product of positive integers.
It's unique up to units.
We can always put units either
on the integer that we're
factoring or on any of the
factors, and we can freely
multiply any of these things by
units, and it won't affect
the factorization.
Similarly over here, when
we talk about unique
factorization, we mean
unique up to units.
We're basically going to talk
about the factorization of
monic polynomials into a product
of monic polynomials.
Not getting a real positive
feeling that everybody's
following me.
Would it help if I wrote
down more things,
or wrote some examples?
In F2 of x, for instance,
we have --
well, this isn't a very
good example.
Let's write R of x.
OK?
We're going to talk about
factorizations like this. x
squared minus 1 equals x
minus 1 times x plus 1.
That's a factorization of a
monic polynomial into a
product of monic polynomials
of a lower degree.
Happens in F2 of x.
Since there is only one non-zero
field element, then
all polynomials are monic,
except for the 0 polynomial.
The only non-zero term we
have play with is one.
So the highest order non-zero
term is always 1.
All right.
OK.
So that's what we're going to
mean by unique factorization.
Now, there's one other
qualifier.
There's some trivial factors.
We took some care to use the
standard mathematical
terminology in the notes, so if
it says trivial devisors,
then that's what I mean.
What would the trivial divisors
of integer n be?
1 and n are always going
to divide in.
And we're really not interested
in those when we
talk about factorization.
Similarly, over here, the
trivial divisor of a
polynomial F of x are
1 and F of x.
We're not interested in those.
So when we talk about unique
factorization, we mean up to
units and nontrivial factors.
And for the integers, that means
that we're going to talk
about divisors d, let's
say, such that d is
between 1 and n.
And for polynomials, what this
means is we're not interested
in degree 0 factors.
The only factor of degree the
same as F of x is going to be
F of x up to units.
We're interested in divisors d
of x such that the degree that
0 is less than the degree of
the divisor less than the
degree of what it's
dividing into.
Sorry.
I'm not defining everything,
but I hope that's clear.
We're just interested in factors
that have degree less
than the polynomial that we're
factoring, but we're not
interested in degree
0 factors.
So that's what's meant by
unique factorization.
It also shows you the
analogy in general.
In the case of integers, the key
thing in a divisor is that
it have magnitude
between 1 and n.
The key thing in a polynomial
is it have degree between 0
and the degree of F of x.
Basically, we want to factor
something into
smaller things here.
And when we say smaller, we
talk about magnitude.
Here when we say smaller, we're
talking about degrees.
In general, we go between
these two things.
The concept of magnitude is
replaced by the concept of
degree, to say how
big something is.
In both of these, the key to
all proofs is the Euclidean
division algorithm.
Suppose we want to see if
n is a divisor of m.
I've forgotten what I
put in the notes.
Then we go through division, and
we find that m is equal to
q, some quotient times n,
plus a remainder r.
This is standard grade
school division.
But it's really the key in the
universe in talking about
these two domains.
And this is what we've used,
really, to prove everything
about the factorization
properties of integers.
And how would you actually prove
that everything can be
written this way?
There's an important caveat.
That the remainder we can always
choose to have to be in
the range from 0 less
than r less than or
equal to n minus 1.
And the remainder is what
we call m mod n.
We divide and we get a remainder
that's one of these
n things, and that's the main
thing we get out of this
division, is m mod n, which is
equal to the remainder r.
And there are precisely
n remainders.
Now, how do you actually
prove this?
You prove this, if
you want, very
easily, just by recursion.
You take m, and you ask, is
it already in this range?
If it is, you're done.
m is the remainder
and q is zero.
If not, then you subtract n from
m, thereby reducing the
magnitude of m.
You can use the magnitude as an
indicator of how far you've
gotten in this process.
You reduce the magnitude, and
then you ask, is the result in
this range?
OK.
If it's in that range, fine,
you finish this and q is 1.
Otherwise, you continue.
And in the recursion, you're
continually reducing the
magnitude, and it's easy to
show that eventually, the
magnitude has to fall into this
range and be one of these
n remainder numbers, and
then you're done.
OK?
So it's a descending chain
where the chain
has a bottom at 0.
If you start with a positive
integer, you can't go below 0.
And this is the only way
it can come out.
Very easy to prove that.
All right.
Similarly in polynomials, we get
an analogous expression.
If we want to take F of x and
see if G of x is a divisor, we
take F of x, and we can always
write this as some quotient
times G of x plus
some remainder.
Where the important thing here
about the remainder is that
the degree of the remainder
is less than the
degree of G of x.
And here the remainder is called
F of x mod G of x.
Just as the remainder here
is called m mod n.
And there's a unique
remainder.
And again, how would
you prove this?
You could just take any long
division algorithm that you
know for dividing G
of x into F of x.
Basically long division amounts
to taking F of x.
You can always choose some
scalar multiple of G of x such
that F of x minus alpha G of x
has degree less than F of x.
So you pick the top term to
reduce the degree, all right?
Let's take G of x to be monic.
We're only interested in
monic polynomials.
If the top term of F of x is --
well, we're only going to
divide it into monic
polynomials.
But as we go along, we may
get non-monic ones.
So you take the top
term, whatever it
is over here, f(m).
You multiply f(m)
times g of x.
You subtract f(m) g
of x from f of x.
You reduce the degree.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Correct.
Thank you very much.
You need also a term x to
whatever the difference in
degrees is here to move the
degree up to the top.
When we're actually doing long
division, we write f(m) f(m
minus 1) down to f(0).
We divide g(n) down to g(1).
And the first term, g(n) is
going to be equal to 1.
We take f(m) up here.
We implicitly move it over to
get f(m) dot dot dot dot, down
to f(m) alpha.
We subtract, and we're down
to something that only has
degree m minus 1.
That's what polynomial long
division is shorthand for.
So you all know how
to do this.
OK.
Again, similar kind of proof,
that you must be able to get a
remainder in this range,
and furthermore, the
remainder is unique.
You basically can go through
this process.
You reduce the degree by at
least one every time.
Therefore, degree must
eventually be reduced to where
it's less than degree g of x.
At that point, you can't
continue this process.
You're stuck.
And that's your remainder.
There's no way of taking
something of lesser degree of
g of x and then subtracting some
multiple from g of x from
it to still further
reduce the degree.
All right.
So similar proof.
Uniqueness is pretty obvious.
So you get a unique remainder of
lesser degree than g of x.
And so you can reduce any f of
x to some remainder r of x,
which is called f
of x mod g of x.
And if we do arithmetic, the way
we do arithmetic over here
for addition is we just, if we
want to add two remainders mod
n, we take the sum of them, and
then if necessary, reduce
them mod n.
Similarly with multiplication.
If we want to multiply them,
we take the product of two
remainders, and if necessary,
reduce them again to a
legitimate remainder which is
in this range or to mod n.
It's the same over here.
If we want to add two
remainders, that's easy enough.
We can do that and we won't
increase the degree, so we
automatically get something
when we add two remainders
that satisfies this
degree property.
We don't have to reduce
mod g of x.
If we multiply, you do have to
check that when you multiply
two remainders, then all you
need to do is reduce
the mod g of x.
And basically, the assertion
is that --
let's see. r of x, s of x --
it's hard to write this without
being tautological.
r of x, s of x.
Reduced mod n, I'm sorry,
mod g of x.
I'm sorry.
This is not worth writing.
r of x, s of x, mod g of x.
Something like that.
Bah.
It's a total tautology.
Forget it.
Said correctly in the notes.
I'd rather think of it
as residue classes.
If we, say, we talk about this
as a coset, f of x plus r of
x, and we want to multiply
any element.
This coset times any element
of the coset f
of x plus s of x.
Then the result is just
multiplying out symbolically
the polynomials times the
polynomials are the
polynomials.
Any polynomial times a
polynomial is a polynomial.
Plus r of x f of x.
We could get some multiple
of r of x,
some polynomial multiple.
We could get some polynomial
multiple of s of x.
Plus r of x s of x.
But this is a polynomial that's
included in here.
We don't need to
say that again.
Similarly here.
And so this is equal
to f of x.
It's equal to the coset f
of x plus r of x s of x.
But this is another
polynomial that
probably has higher degree.
This is equal to the coset
f of x plus r of x s
of x mod g of x.
OK.
So this tells us that to
multiply cosets, coset with
representative r of x times the
coset with representative
s of x, we're going to get
something in the coset whose
representative is r of
x, s of x mod g of x.
So this is a sketch of a proof
that basically mod g of x
commutes with multiplication.
To multiply r of
x times s of x.
All right.
So --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You're quite correct.
What I mean is the cosets
of g of x of f of x.
So I now understand all
the blank looks.
Are we better off now?
We have a group consisting of
the set of all multiples of g
of x, which I write as g of x
times all the polynomials.
The cosets of the group
are precisely --
there's one remainder of degree
less than g of x in
every coset.
So this is the representative
of the coset.
This is a sketch of a proof that
multiplication basically
just amounts to multiplying
the remainders.
The representative of the
product coset is the product
of the representatives
modulo g of x.
I think I said it correctly
for once.
Please read the notes if you are
still confused, as I can
see some of you are.
Maybe it would help
to do an example.
Let's take g of x to be equal
to x squared plus x
plus 1 in f2 of x.
It's a binary polynomial.
Then r of x.
The remainders are
equal to 0,1.
This was degree minus infinity,
this is degree 0.
They're x or x plus one.
OK?
These are the possible
remainders when I take any
polynomial modulo g of x.
Divide it by g of x, and I'm
going to get a polynomial in
f2 of x of degree less than or
equal to 1, and those are all
of the polynomials that are
decisively for degree less
than or equal to 1.
All right?
So what's the addition table?
Addition is pretty easy.
0 plus anything is itself.
1 plus 1 in F2 is simply 0.
1 plus x is 1 plus x, sorry,
x plus 1 as I've written.
And 1 plus x plus 1 is x.
x, x plus 1.
x plus x is what?
Hello?
0.
Thank you.
x plus x plus 1?
x plus 1, x.
x plus x plus 1, 1, and 0.
So that's what the addition
table looks like.
Actually you could think of
these as being just written as
binary pairs, 0 0, 0 1, 1 0,
1 1, where this pair is
basically F1 F0.
And then the addition table is
precisely the same as the
addition table for these
binary 2-tuples.
You just add, component-wise,
the lowest order coefficient,
the F1 coefficient.
So addition is just like
addition in F2 squared.
Or z2 squared, if you like.
OK.
That's actually an
additive group.
Check it out.
It's not z4 by the way.
The other abelian group, or the
other group of size four,
sometimes called the Klein
four-group, but it's really
just the addition table for
the set of all binary
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
two-tuples.
OK?
Multiplication.
One very nice thing about
finite fields is
you can simply --
sorry.
This was supposed to be
addition, this was supposed to
be multiplication.
You know can simply write out
what all the rules are in a
finite space.
OK.
So what's 0 times anything?
What's 1 times anything?
Itself.
1 is the multiplicative
identity.
But you know.
You could formally do this
by doing polynomial
multiplication.
All right.
Here's an interesting one.
What's x times x?
Do x times x.
What is that going
to be equal to?
x plus 1.
How did you do that?
We did the modulo.
First of all, we write that
that's x squared.
But then we have to do x
squared modulo g of x.
x squared plus x plus 1.
So we have to go through a
little long division process.
We have to subtract this
out from that.
And that gives us x plus 1.
So that's the key rule.
Whenever we see something of
degree two or higher, we can
always reduce it by subtracting
out some multiple
of g of x down to something
of lower degree.
Right?
So this is what I've
been talking about.
So x times x is x plus 1.
What's x times x plus 1?
Equals what?
Good.
You can do that in your heads.
And what's x plus 1
times x plus 1?
Remember, we're doing
mod-2 arithmetic in
our base field here.
So this equals what?
x squared plus 1.
We reduce that, we get x.
OK.
Let me check right now.
Is this a field?
These four elements with these
rules for addition and
multiplication.
Does that form a field?
What do I have to check, apart
from formalities like the
distributive law?
Which follows from the
distributive law for
polynomials.
That's always going to hold
through mod x arithmetic.
What do I have to check?
What are my field axioms?
Anybody?
Closure under multiplication.
That's getting towards a very
crisp statement of the --
I'm looking for two
group axioms.
One has to do with something we
have to check for addition.
Something has to do with
something we have to check for
multiplication.
Inverses?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Between the two of you I heard
the two answers that I want.
We have to check that
this forms an
abelian group under addition.
So we have to check that the
addition table is the addition
table of an abelian group.
And under multiplication, we
have to check that the
non-zero elements form
a billion group.
So just this part of the table
has to form an abelian group,
and both these have to have
an identity, of course.
But the identity in mod g of x
arithmetic is always going to
be 0 for addition and it's
always going to be 1 for
multiplication.
All right.
So I check this.
Is this a group table?
Basically, I just have to check
whether every row and
column is a permutation
of the elements.
And it is.
And 0 acts as 0 should act.
Has the additive identity.
All right?
Here what I have to check is
that the nonzero elements,
these three, form an abelian
group under multiplication.
Well, there really is only
one group of size three.
It is isomorphic to Z3.
If I replace --
let's remember what Z3 looks
like under addition.
This looks like 0 1 2,
0 1 2, 0 1 2, 0 1 2.
It's mod-3.
1 plus 1 is 2, 1 plus 2 is 3,
which is 0, 1 plus 2 is 3,
which is 0, 2 plus 2 equals 1.
So gee whiz.
This is isomorphic to that if I
relabel 1 by 0, x by 1, and
x plus 1 by 2.
That's the only thing
it could be.
The only group table in which
every row and column is a
permutation of every other.
OK?
So we verified that we
now have a finite
field with four elements.
Prime power number
of elements.
Right?
The elements of my field are
these four remainders, or you
can think of them as
representatives for their
cosets, modulo g of x.
The addition rule is addition
modulo g of x, and the
multiplication rule is
multiplication modulo g of x.
And it satisfies the field
axioms, therefore, it's a
finite field.
All right?
I can add, subtract.
Addition and subtraction
basically looks like addition
and subtraction of binary
two-tuples, just
component-wise.
Multiplication is a little
bit more mysterious
right now, but it works.
Let me tell you where we're
going to go on multiplication.
In this case, I can write x
plus 1 in a different way.
I note that x plus 1 is
equal to x squared.
All right?
So let me write a little
log table over here for
multiplication purposes.
I'm going to write x --
I'm going to call that alpha.
And x plus 1 is equal
to x squared,
or it's alpha squared.
What's alpha cubed?
Alpha cubed is x times
this again.
Let me look in the table. x
times x plus 1 is equal to 1.
So 1 equals alpha cubed.
Or I could write that
as alpha to 0.
If I multiply by x again,
I just cycle.
So I'm going to get a
cyclic group here.
And now I'm going to write the
multiplication table as follows.
I'm going to write the elements
of the group as 1,
alpha, alpha squared, 0, 1,
alpha, alpha squared.
Again, 0 times anything is 0.
We never have to worry
about that.
1, alpha, alpha squared.
Alpha times alpha is
alpha squared.
Alpha times alpha squared
is alpha cubed.
But that's equal to 1.
Same here.
Alpha squared times
alpha squared --
what's that?
Alpha to the fourth, but what
does alpha fourth equal to if
alpha cubed is equal to 1?
This has to be equal to alpha.
Point is, because of this
relationship here, I can
always reduce the exponents
modulo 3.
I've basically got a little
multiplicative cyclic group of
order three that's, of course,
isomorphic to the
additive group, Z3.
So there are two ways I
can do multiplication.
One is, I can do it by
this mod g of x way.
I can represent things by these
which basically stand
for polynomials of degree
one or less.
And I can multiply two of these
by simply going through
standard polynomial
multiplication over the
appropriate field.
And then I'll likely get some
powers of x squared or higher,
and I reduce those to modulo
x squared plus x plus 1.
That's legitimate and that
gives me this statement.
Well, the other thing I can do
is for multiplication, I can
have a different
representation.
This is basically just
a log table.
OK?
For each, I would have in my
little computer a separate
table where I'd write that this
corresponds to 0, 0 1
corresponds to 1, 1 0
corresponds to alpha, and 1 1
corresponds to alpha squared.
Or of course, I would just
represent these by their
exponents that have some
special value for 0.
And then all I have to do is
add exponents modulo 3 for
multiplication.
So log of x is 1, log of x plus
1 is 2, log of 1 is 0,
and then I just use this for my
multiplication operation,
or equivalently this cyclic
multiplicative group.
Then I go through some inverse
log operation to get back to
the other representation,
if I wanted to.
And in fact, in finite field
arithmetic, this is what's
typically done.
There's just a little table
lookup such that you can go
back and forth between this
representation, which we use
for addition, and this
for multiplication.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: You have to represent
it as being special
in some way.
So if, in fact, literally, I
made log x equal to 1, log x
plus 1 equal to 2, log
1 equal to 0 --
one thing I suggest in the
notes, you can make log 0
equal to minus infinity.
That will always work.
If you ever multiply
by 0, you'll be
adding minus infinity.
The result will be minus
infinity, so the
inverse log is 0.
So that's one way
you can do it.
Or you could do what you do in
ordinary real and complex
arithmetic.
You could just, say, have
some special routine for
multiplication by
0 is always 0.
Division by 0 is illegal.
Put out some error message.
All right?
So that's how you actually build
a little finite field
computer for this
finite field.
OK.
Now, I chose this advisedly.
Suppose I have chosen g of x
equal to x squared plus 1.
OK?
I can do mod g of x arithmetic
for x squared plus 1.
Again, my four field elements
are going to be the four
binary polynomials of
degree 1 or less.
The addition table is going
to be exactly the same.
So let's just write the
multiplication table over here.
0, 1, x, x plus 1, 0,
1, x, x plus 1.
0 times anything is 0 in
ordinary polynomial
multiplication, and therefore
also in mod g of x
for any g of x.
1 times anything is itself.
No problem there.
x, x plus 1.
So we again have to give a
little bit care to x squared.
What's that going
to be equal to?
1.
And x times x plus 1
is equal to what?
x squared plus x is
equal to what?
Looks like there's a problem.
x plus 1 times x squared x plus
1 is equal to x squared
plus 1, what's that equal?
0.
Yuck.
Didn't work.
What's the essential
problem here?
Yeah.
This clearly is not a group.
It's not even closed under
multiplication.
Because x plus 1 times x
plus 1 is equal to 0.
The essential problem is that
there are two polynomials of
degree less than two whose
product is x squared plus 1.
In other words, this
is factorizable.
OK?
In F2 of x.
All right?
So whereas x squared
plus x plus 1.
Does that have any factors
of degree 1 or less?
Any nontrivial factors
Well, basically we proved that
it didn't, when we wrote this
multiplication table.
We tried all products of degree
1 or less polynomials
where they're both non-zero,
and we never got 0.
So this will work if and only if
g of x is irreducible, has
no nontrivial factors, is
a prime polynomial.
These are all equivalent
in F2 of x.
There's this distinction in
other fields that irreducible
just means has no nontrivial
factors.
Prime means there's a monic
polynomial with
no non-trivial factors.
So that's what I
said back here.
That the way we're ultimately
going to have to construct
finite fields is take the
polynomials in Fp, Fp of x --
we've been looking
at F2 of x --
modulo a prime polynomial
g of x.
So what we're going to need to
find is prime polynomials.
Let's see.
Can I already prove that this is
going to work for any prime
polynomial?
So I'm going to force the g of
x to be equal to a prime
polynomial in Fp of
x of degree m.
All right
For example, x squared plus x
plus 1 is a prime polynomial.
And I'm going to ask if the
remainders mod g of x form a
field under mod g
of x arithmetic.
OK.
Let's flow this out
a little bit.
Again, what are the remainders
going to be of any polynomial
of degree m?
So this is basically going to
be the polynomials of degree
less than m in Fp of x.
How many of them are
there, by the way?
p to the m.
So the size of this
is p to the m.
And one of the representations
for these polynomials is just
to write out F0, F1,
up to m minus 1.
So this just basically looks
like the polynomial m-tuples.
Set of F0, F1 up to F minus 1,
for each of these an element
of the field.
OK?
I can make a one-to-one
correspondence between the
polynomials of degree less
than m and the set of all
coefficient m-tuples over Fp.
These are just m-tuples
over Fp.
So there are p to
the m of them.
And so it's a finite set,
size p to the m.
Does it form a field under
mod g of x arithmetic?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Correct.
And that's a homework problem.
So I'm not going to do it in
class, but I will sketch here
how it's going to be done.
But I'm glad that you
instantly see that.
Because again, we just model
everything we do on what we
did for integers.
If you remember how we proved
it for integers.
First of all, we really need
to check two things.
Addition.
Just as we did for this specific
example up here, we
first have to check that the
addition table is that of an
abelian group, that these
supposed field elements form
an abelian group
under addition.
And we've already observed
several times that addition is
just basically component-wise
addition of these m-tuples.
So it's just like
vector addition.
And vector addition, of course,
has the group property.
So addition is basically just
like vector addition.
Or I could write, perhaps more
precisely, Zp over m.
Distinction without a
difference, really.
So it's just component-wise
addition of the coefficients.
That's how we do polynomial
addition.
And it will give us a remainder
that has a degree of
less than m, so we don't have
to have ever reduce it.
Modulo g of x, we just simply
add component-wise.
OK.
So that's easy to verify.
The addition table is always
going to be OK.
So what do we have
to prove now?
We have to --
what am I going to call these?
Rg of x.
The remainders mod g of x.
For multiplication, we have to
prove that Rg of x star --
the non-zero polynomials form an
abelian group, which, as I
say, it's a homework problem.
Let me sketch the proof.
It's precisely analogous
to the proof that
we made for Zp star.
We basically have to
check closure.
If we multiply two non-zero
polynomials, do we get another
non-zero polynomial?
Asking another way, is it
possible to multiply two
polynomials of degree less than
m and get a result which
is a multiple of g of x, which
is either equal to g of x or a
multiple of g of x?
And it's, I think, easy to
convince yourself if this has
no factors --
its only factors are
itself and 1, no
non-trivial factors --
then you can't multiply two
lesser degree polynomials and
get either g of x, of course,
or any multiple of g of x.
And it's an exercise
for the student to
write that proof out.
OK?
But it's just exactly analogous
to the proof that
you can't multiply two integers
less than a prime p
and get a multiple of p.
So use that as a model, if you
want to, in your proof.
That of course depends
on this being prime.
If this is factorizable,
non-prime, then of course
there are going to be two
nontrivial factors, two
remainders of degree less than
m, whose product is equal to g
of x itself, if it's
factorizable.
So you can't possibly
get closure.
So this is why non-prime
polynomials don't work, just
like non-prime integers don't
work when we constructed Fp.
Exactly analogous reasons.
All right.
Second question is, when we go
through this multiplication,
suppose we take r
of x times --
let's construct a multiplication
table.
Let's take a particular row.
Let's take r of x times all
the non-zero things.
Can we possibly get
any repeats?
Can r of x times s of x equal
r of x times t of x?
And again, it's easy to convince
yourself that that's
not possible.
If that were possible, then r of
x times s of x minus t of x
would be equal to 0.
And so we're back to where
we were before --
mod g of x.
And this is impossible.
These are both degrees
less than m.
We can't multiply two things
of lower degree together to
get a multiple of g of x.
So it can't equal 0.
That means there can't
be any repeats.
That means that each row
is a permutation
of every other row.
Similarly for columns.
If you want to do that,
all you have to
actually prove is one.
So every row or column is a
permutations of every other
one, if we just look at the
non-zero polynomials, star.
And therefore, this forms an
abelian group whose identity
is always one.
Just as we proved up here.
So this depends on
irreducibility.
Depends on no nontrivial
factors of g of x.
OK.
And that's all we
have to check.
So I claim that by this process,
I can, given a prime
polynomial in Fp of x of degree
m, I can construct a
finite field with p to the m
elements, that the addition
and multiplication rules can
be taken as mod g of x
arithmetic, and they will
satisfy the field axioms.
So you can now construct a
finite field for any prime
power p to the m, right?
There's actually still
a hole in this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Define prime
polynomial?
The term, or --
AUDIENCE: Define the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] of degree m.
PROFESSOR: Correct.
Is there going to be a prime
polynomial of every degree?
I don't know.
Suppose you want to define an
irreducible polynomial over,
say, F2 of x or F3
of x of degree 4.
Could you do that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Beautiful.
I mean, that's an excellent
suggestion.
So the question is, does there
exist a prime polynomial in Fp
of x of every degree?
Or of a given degree?
And there are various ways of
attacking this question.
First of all, I'll tell
you the answer is yes.
For every p and every m, there
does exist a prime polynomial.
Which is fortunate.
So from that, we conclude there
is a finite field with p
to the m elements for every
prime p and every m greater
than or equal to 1.
Now, how might we prove that?
One is, look it up on Google.
You can certainly formulate a
question that will lead you to
a webpage that will have a
listing of all the prime
polynomials of all degrees over
any field that you're
interested in.
So perhaps that will
suffice for you.
Two.
What I'm going to talk about
is the sieve method.
Three.
You could do a bound on the
number of polynomials of each
degree in d, and show that
it's greater than
or equal to 1, always.
And this is done in the notes.
Section 7.9 I think.
Or four, you can do what Mr.
Agarwal has suggested.
You can actually do the closed
form combinatoric
formula, which --
I haven't done any number
theory here.
There's a little bit of
elementary number
theory in the notes.
Euler numbers, this
sort of thing.
We get formulas for the number
of integers degree d that --
well, number of integers that
have multiplicative orders d
mod n, and so forth.
It's a lovely combinatoric
field.
There is a lovely closed form
for this that you get from the
Mobius inversion formula.
And it can be found in
combinatoric books.
I know it's in Berlekamp's
Algebraic Coding Theory book.
And it's extremely pretty.
And then of course, given the
formula, you have to prove to
all of the --
again, n of d is greater
than or equal to 1.
But there is a closed form
expression for it that you get
out of combinatorics.
We're not going to
do that here.
I'll be satisfied --
well, this is the real
engineering solution here.
This is the mathematical
engineering solution.
And what do I mean by
the sieve method?
Again, take the analogy
with the integers.
One of the first mathematical
accomplishments was
Eratosthenes' sieve for
finding prime numbers.
How does it work?
You start to write
down all the --
well.
Imagine first writing down
all the integers.
All right?
Cross off 1.
Start with 2.
All right.
So the first prime is 2.
Then you cross off all
multiples of 2.
4,6,8, so forth.
OK?
So what's the next number that
you haven't crossed off?
It's 3, so that's
the next prime.
You cross off all the
multiples of 3.
3,6,9.
So forth.
15.
And thereby you continue.
So the steps are, find the
next integer on the list.
That's going to be a prime,
because it won't have been
crossed off by any
previous steps.
It's not a multiple of any
integer of lower degree.
Then cross off all of its
multiples, up to however long
your scribe has written
this on the tablet.
And this way, you can find
the primes up to
any number you want.
Gets kind of tedious after a
while, but you can certainly
find all the primes
up to 100 in a few
minutes doing this, right?
Well, it's the same for
integers, and it's the same
for polynomials.
So let's, for instance,
do a polynomial sieve.
Of course, what we're most
interested in is the
polynomials with binary
coefficients, F2 of x.
And how do we do it?
Let's write down --
let's forget about 0 and 1.
Those are not considered
to be prime.
Let's start with the degree
1 polynomials.
What are the degree
one polynomials?
They're x, x plus 1.
Are these factorizable?
Obviously their only factors
are one and themselves.
They have no nontrivial
factors.
So these are primes.
OK.
So now let's write down all the
polynomials of degree two.
I'm sort of doing this in
an interleaved manner.
There are going to be two of
degree 1, four of degree 2.
All I'm going to do is -- well,
the only polynomials are
monic in F2 of x, so I don't
have to make that
qualification.
All right.
So here are the four
of degree 2, right?
Now I go through with my sieve
and we take out all
multiples of x.
Multiples of x are polynomials
with 0 constant term, right?
A lowest order term.
So obviously this is a multiple
of x, this is a
multiple of x.
Multiples of x plus 1.
How do you recognize those
over the binary field?
This is basically the polynomial
whose root is 1.
That means the mod-2 sum of the
coefficients is equal to 0.
So any polynomial that has an
even number of non-zero
coefficients is divisible
by x plus 1.
Did you all get that?
If not, try that at home.
That's the easy way to recognize
whether something is
a multiple of x plus 1.
It has an even number of
non-zero coefficients.
So this is a multiple
of x plus 1.
We wrote it out explicitly.
It's x plus 1 squared in F2
of x, and this is not.
So there is only one prime
polynomial over F2 of x
that's degree 2.
So this is our only possible
choice if we want to construct
a finite field with
four elements,
due to the two elements.
OK.
So that might begin
to get us scared.
Is it possible that
there are no prime
polynomials of degree three?
Well, we had two
here, one here.
Is it going down?
Let's write down the polynomials
of degree 3.
x third, x third plus 1, x to
the three plus x, to the three
plus x plus 1, x to the three
plus x squared, x to the three
plus x squared plus 1, x to the
three plus x squared plus
x, x to the three plus x
squared plus x plus 1.
Eight of them.
So that's working
in our favor.
There's double the number
of polynomials as we
go up one in degree.
And again, let's go
through the sieve.
Which are multiples of x,
non-zero constant term?
Which are multiples of x plus
1, even number of non-zero
coefficients?
If you doubt that,
write it out.
Which are multiples of x
squared plus x plus 1?
Well, they're going to have to
be x squared plus x plus 1
times x plus 1 or times x, so
we've already got them.
If we take this times itself,
we're going to get a
polynomial of degree 4.
Not going to be on this list.
So we have to multiply
this by these.
We've already got those.
So whew.
We found two.
We could use either of these
to construct a finite field
with eight elements.
And so forth.
And it turns out as you go up
to higher degrees, that the
number now increases very
nicely, and there's no problem
finding a prime polynomial
of each degree.
And in fact, you could be cute
about it and try to find one
with only three non-zero terms,
or has some other nice
property that makes it easy
to calculate with.
And so forth.
So do you understand
the sieve method?
If you do, then I believe
you could find a --
suppose you want to construct
a field with 64 elements.
What do you need?
64 is 2 to the sixth, so
you're going to need a
polynomial with p equals
2 and m equals 6.
You're going to need a binary
polynomial of degree 6 that is
prime, irreducible.
And again, in a few minutes
by going through the sieve
process, you can quickly find
one, or you could look it up
in Google, or in Peterson's
book, or any algebraic coding
theory book, or probably
a lot of other places.
So this is a practical solution
for the problem for
any given p and m.
Of course, it hardly proves
that there's one of every
degree, because they're
kind of an
infinite number of degrees.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So there's two order
3 polynomials that are prime.
Will it generate two separate
fields, or are they going to
be isomorphic to each other?
PROFESSOR: Great question.
All fields with p to the m
elements are isomorphic to
each other.
That's proved in the notes.
I'm not going to
do it in class.
And the other thing that's
proved in the notes is the
analog to Zp.
There are no other finite fields
with other than p to
the m number of elements.
OK?
So this is it.
Now, if you explicitly write
out these two, and
write out their --
well, the addition tables are
always look the same, because
it's always just binary
three-tuples, in this case.
But multiplication tables are
going to look different.
But there is some isomorphism.
x and 1 may be equivalent to x
squared plus 1 on the other
one, or something.
But if you go through that
isomorphism, you'll find that
the field tables are the same.
Actually, I guess I'm going to
prove that, because I'm going
to prove that the
multiplication
table is always cyclic.
That the group to which it's
isomorphic is z mod p
to the m minus 1.
Just as it was to Z3 here.
And I guess that's sufficient
with the addition table
isomorphism.
I guess you have to prove
they're equivalent.
You saw it in a different
way in the notes.
But you're going to see that all
the multiplication group
is always a cyclic group, with
p to the m minus 1 elements,
and that goes a long way towards
suggesting that these
are always going to be
isomorphic to each other.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Identify
roots, right?
PROFESSOR: Identify roots?
If I understand what you're
saying, that's basically the
way it's done in the notes.
You first show there's always
going to be some primitive
element that generates
the cyclic group.
Some single generator such that
alpha alpha squared, so
forth, is the entire
non-zero set.
You're going to show that
alpha has some minimal
polynomial, and the set of all
linear combinations of powers
of alpha is basically equal
to the whole field.
And so this allows you to
establish the isomorphism.
and I think that's what
you're suggesting.
So you're well equipped to read
the notes, but I'm not
going to do that in class.
Yeah.
I'm very interested
in your questions.
Please ask more, as many
questions as you like.
What I'm getting from it is,
you know, you all come from
different backgrounds.
Some of you have seen this in
perhaps a math context, or
some other context, or you've
seen parts of it, or some of
the words are familiar.
And of course, there are many
different ways to present this
and to make the proofs
and so forth.
So I'm trying to pick a line
that works for the particular
results that I want to get to.
I don't think you would do
anything much different if you
wanted to develop
finite fields.
But the class has a very
different set of backgrounds,
and I'm trying to reach
all of you.
Don't be alarmed if
you've never seen
anything like this before.
You're not way behind everybody
else, either.
I think it's pretty easy
to understand.
Maybe it would take you a
couple hours longer than
somebody who has more
background, but
not more than that.
OK.
So that's how we construct
finite fields.
You have an example of it.
Goodness.
Is it really 11 o'clock?
OK.
So I'm not even --
so I've simply asserted,
but not proved.
You saw in this case that the
multiplicative group was a
cyclic group.
And we could always, for
multiplication, represent
grouped elements by
this log table.
So I'd hoped to prove
that in class.
I'm not going to be able
to prove that in class.
And I'll simply ask you
to read that, too.
This is important for working
with finite fields, because it
is the way, probably the
preferred way, to implement
multiplication.
So you ought to be thinking of
how you would program up a
finite field multiplier.
One way is polynomial
multiplication.
The other way is just use the
fact that the multiplicative
group is cyclic.
And then it's easy.
Just add exponents and reduce
modulo q minus 1.
OK.
I'm sorry not to have had a
chance to go over that.
Next time, Ralf Koetter will
start to get into chapter
eight, Reed-Solomon codes.